امريكا تحرك شبح البحار النوويه لتحط
رحالها في الشرق الاوسط رئيس الاستخبارات
الامريكيه في تلابيب مستهدفا زياره الدول
عربيه ما الهدف نتنياهو يوجه رساله لخصوم
تل ابيب واصدقائها استقالات جماعيه في
بريطانيا بسبب ما يحدث في القطاع تلا ابيب
تحشد الدعم الدولي لتهجير الغزاويين الى
مصر بعد تاهب جيش العراق رئيس الوزراء يصل
الى طهران الصين وولى رئاسه مجلس الامن
وتتعهد بانهاء الحرب في الشرق الاوسط
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعلن عن فرصه اخيره لحل
الصراع في الشرق الاوسط الجزائر تدعو الى
مقاضاه الكيان امام محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه زلن سكي لا يوجد بديل لمساعدتنا
لقد يئسنا وهديه غير متوقعه تنهي حياه
نائب قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
والهند توجه انتقادات لاذعه للجانب الغربي
تحركات مخيفه قلق في واشنطن يعتري الاداره
الامريكيه لانهاء الصراع في الشرق الاوسط
باقرب وقت فالوضع يتجه للخروج عن نطاقه
حتى ان الولايات المتحده ارسلت رئيس
المخابرات الامريكيه وليم بيرنز في زياره
خاطفه الى الكيان في خضم الزيارات المكثفه
لمسؤولين امريكيين رفيعي المستوى الى
الشرق الاوسط وتلبي بشكل خاص منذ اندلاع
المواجهه في اكتوبر الماضي تاتي تلك
الزياره في وقت حرج يتعرض فيه قاده
المخابرات الرئيسيين في تل ابيب لانتقادات
عنيفه بسبب فشلهم في اكتشاف الهجوم
المباغت الذي شنته الفصائل قبل وقوعه
بيرنز سيزور دولا عربيه على غرار مصر
والامارات وقد يزور قطر بحسب موقع وايت
هذا وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن قد ذهب في زياره لم يعلن عنها
مسبقا للعراق في اطار جولته بالشرق الاوسط
الهادفه لخفض التوتر بعد دلاع الحرب وبعد
اعلان الجيش العراقي التاهب العسكري زياره
مفاجئه من رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني لطهران وذلك بعد يوم من لقاء
بلينكن لتعلن القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
ان الغواصه النوويه من طراز اوهايو التي
تدعى بشبح البحار وصلت الى منطقه مسؤوليه
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه بالشرق الاوسط
لتنضم اوهايو الى حاملتي الطائرات
ايزنهاور وجرل فورد ومجموعه السفن الحرب
التابعه لهما والتي سبق ان نشرهما الجيش
الامريكي في المنطقه تعتبر اوهايو من ضمن
الغواصات الضخمه التابعه للبحريه
الامريكيه التي تستخدم للردع النووي وهي
قادره على اطلاق الصواريخ البالستيه
وصواريخ كروز كما تستطيع ان تحمل 24 صاروخ
ترايدنت النووي بالاضافه الى العديد من
الاسلحه التقليديه الاخرى وقد صممت اوهايو
للعمليات السريه والقتال تحت الماء ولديها
القدره على البقاء تحت ال ماء لمده تصل
الى ثلاثه اشهر من جهته اعلن رئيس الوزراء
الاردني بشر الخصاونه ان اي محاولات
لتهجير الغزاويين او ابناء الضفه خط احمر
وسيعتبر الاردن بمثابه اعلان حرب هناك خرج
رئيس وزراء الكيان ليوجه رساله للخصوم
والاصدقاء حيث قالت صحيفتها ارتس انه رفض
خلال لقاء مع صحفيين تحمل مسؤوليه الفشل
الامني في اكتوبر الماضي مشيره الى ان
جانتس طالبه بالتراجع عن تصريحاته فورا في
تداعيات هذه الحرب على الساحه الدوليه
استقالات جماعيه بريطانيه فقد اعلن زعيم
مجلس مدينه بيرنلي بمقاطعه لانكش شمال غرب
بريطانيا وعشره اعضاء اخرين من حزب العمال
البريطاني استقالاتهم لعدم دعم زعيم الحزب
كيرس تمر طلب وقف اطلاق النار في القطاع
وفي تصريح قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان
بيكين ستبذل قصار جهدها لاستعاده السلام
في الشرق الاوسط وعلى راسه القطاع وذلك مع
توليها رئاسه مجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده وسط تصاعد التوتر في الشرق الاوسط
اما مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل فاعتبر ان المجتمع
الدولي لديه فرصه اخيره لحل طويل الامد
للصراع في الشرق الاوسط مضيفا اذا لم ننجح
في حل الدولتين فسنجد انفسنا في دوامه من
الفوضى لننتقل الى الجزائر حيث دع الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون الى رفع دعو
قضائيه ضد الكيان امام المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه والمنظمات الدوليه لحقوق الانسان
وهنا كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
ان الكيان حاول حشد الدعم الدولي لنقل
مئات الالاف من المدنيين من القطاع الى
مخيمات في صحراء سيناء بمصر خلال مده
الحرب وفي اخبار الزحف البري اكد الجيش
العبري شن ضربات كثيفه على القطاع مشيرا
الى نجاحه في تقسيم القطاع الى شطرين بحسب
ما افاد المتحد حدث باسم الجيش العبري
دانييل
هاري حاله من الياس سئمت دول العالم وسئم
الحلفاء والاعداء من الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ليقولها الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي صراحه بان العالم سئم
من الصراع الاوكراني وقال زيلنسكي في
مقابله مع قناه ام بي سي الامريكيه كثير
من الناس في العالم متعبون وهذا امر مفهوم
ووفقا لزل نسكي فان بعض القاده الاوروبيين
تعب ايضا من دعم اوكرانيا وفي الوقت نفسه
فهو مقتنع بانه لا يوجد بديل لمواصله
تقديم المساعده الى كيف ليخرج عضو برلمان
اوكرانيا لكسي جون شرينكو ويقول ان زل
نسكي اوعز لمكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ببدء
التحضير لانتخابات الرئاسه في ربيع
2024 ولكن حتى الان لم يعلق ممثل الاداره
الرئاسيه الاوكرانيه على هذه المعلومات
هذا وصرحت صحيفه ذا سبكتيت البريطانيه بان
الرئيس الاوكراني غير لهجه التواصل مع
الغرب وقالت الصحيفه لقد كان موقف كي في
الاونه الاخيره هو امنحنا المزيد وسوف
نتمكن من الانتصار بسرعه اصبح الان اعطو
المزيد والا فان هذا سوف يستمر الى اجل
غير مسمى في المقابل قال وزير خارجيه
الهند سوبرامانيام جاي شانكار في مقابله
مع صحيفه كوريير ديلا سيره الايطاليه ان
الغرب يطبق العقوبات على روسيا كما لو ان
العالم كله وافق عليها لكن هذا ليس صحيحا
فالتداول الغرب فقط على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
اجمالي خسائر الجيش الاوكراني على ابرز
محاور القتال بلغت نحو 88 فردا خلال يوم
حسب الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه فيما
كان القائد العام للقوات الاوكرانيه
فاليري زالو جني قد اكد عبر قناته وفاه
مساعده جنادي تشس ياكوف مشيرا الى ان عبوه
الناسف كانت موجوده داخل هديه تلقاها
بمناسبه عيد ميلاده تسببت في انهاء حياته
واضاف انه سيتم تحديد الاسباب والظروف
خلال التحقيق
القضائي